the holiday shopping season is in full
swing and stores are offering discounts
pretty early this year black friday is
no longer just one day of sales but
actually the weeks leading up to
thanksgiving kate houston went to arroyo
market square which is right off the 215
in rainbow in the southwest where
shoppers are already noticing those
deals
black friday is more than a week away
and these early deals offer more
flexibility for shoppers that don't want
to arrive at the crack of dawn and deal
with large crowds from electronics to
clothing stores are letting shoppers in
on the discounts early super interesting
to go in there and check out all the
accessories and stuff that they have and
the deals they have going on for black
friday the gels mostly that i've seen is
on electronics a lot of televisions
right now best buy is promoting
guaranteed black friday prices with some
tv's 400 dollars off target is offering
a sneak peek sale going from this sunday
to the day after thanksgiving amazon has
early deals online but some are only for
a limited time frame compared to what
i've seen
previous years i've never seen stuff set
up this early in addition to major
retailers there will now be more local
businesses offering online discounts
than ever before when we were shut down
the direct neighborhood couldn't come in
and they had to find elsewhere to sell
and in order to be competitive they're
out there pushing out the same specials
so you'll likely find a lot of local
deals if you look to their websites
jamie schwartz with the unlv office of
economic development says areas like the
arts district water street and the north
las vegas business corridor are filled
with small businesses eager for new
customers kate houston live local now